[Música]
estados unidos empezó a deportar a
venezolanos a colombia ante el
impedimento de poder devolverlos a su
país de origen las deportaciones se dan
bajo el título 42 una política
instaurada por la administración de
donald trump y mantenida por la de joe
biden que permite expulsar rápidamente a
migrantes por la pandemia de kobe 19 el
gobierno colombiano a través de la
oficina de migración confirmó la llegada
de ciudadanos venezolanos expulsados el
anterior 27 de enero y aseguró que no ha
firmado ningún acuerdo con eeuu para
recibir a 6 mil venezolanos que van a
ser deportados como lo señalan algunos
medios nacionales en colombia y para
ello entonces quiero saludar a nuestro
segundo invitado del día el ex ángel
leal abogado constitucionalista experto
en temas de migración es gracias ángel
por estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24
muy buena mañana y le pregunta entonces
por qué están deportando a los
venezolanos bajo este título 42 esto
podría ser sólo un argumento más para
simplemente deportarlos
bueno
están tratando de efectuar un control
fronterizo y hasta el hasta
recientemente los suramericanos por lo
general están exceptuados de ser
expulsados bajo el título 42 porque
generalmente se trataba de aquellas de
aquellos nativos de países de que
gméxico aceptar es decir mexicanos y
centroamericanos hondureños
guatemaltecos de cara nicaragüenses y
salvadoreños pero que sucede que el caso
de venezolanos en la medida de que ha
ido incrementando el flujo migratorio de
soldados en la frontera sur oeste
entonces buscaba una manera de
implementar el título 42 con los
venezolanos bajo el precepto de que como
en algún momento tuvieron un estatus
legal temporal en colombia aquellos
venezolanos que hayan estado viviendo en
colombia que tuvieron un reasentamiento
establecido en colombia con esta
residencia temporal legal que en teoría
pueden regresar a colombia son los que
están
expulsando 42 a un país donde
presuntamente ocupó un estatus legal
digamos sino así entonces cualquier
venezolano residente legalmente en otro
país no se digamos a argentina o méxico
entonces eeuu los deportar ya donde
tenga el estatus legal esta persona
digamos que no tiene nada que ver con un
acuerdo con el gobierno colombiano sino
el estatus legal que tenga esa persona
en teoría sí pero si usted perdió de la
colaboración
del tercer país porque por ejemplo en el
dado caso que méxico hubiera asestado a
los mencionados pues lo regresarían a
méxico por ejemplo si vienen
provenientes de méxico en la travesía de
llegar a los estados unidos así que en
parte depende de que el extranjero
inmigrante tenga algún algún vínculo
alguna conexión algún estatus legal en
ese país pero también depende de la
disponibilidad del tercer país de
aceptar estos migrantes
generalmente un país acepta a los
migrantes de los cuales son nativos del
país se osea de que se sean nativos de
ese país o en este caso al menos que
tengan algún tipo de estatus
es permanente el dicho país habrá ángel
también el presidente joe biden se ha
mostrado muy contrario digamos sobre
todo en su campaña a las políticas
migratorias del entonces presidente
donald trump porque no elimina esta
medida y digamos ayuda de alguna manera
a esos migrantes que están buscando pues
una una mejor vida en estados unidos
excelente pregunta y muy de acuerdo con
la premisa de su pregunta nos sorprendió
a todos de que la administración bailén
haya seguido con estas expulsiones
bajo el título 42 porque el argumento
legal es que realmente esto ha pasado de
una medida de salud pública a una medida
para efectuar un control migratorio y el
y el título 42 no existe para ese
propósito y realmente lo están
utilizando con ese propósito entonces de
hecho hay dos demandas federales en las
cortes federales del distrito de
columbia washington 16 teniendo que ver
precisamente con este tema hay un caso
muy importante que se llama güiza güiza
versus mayorkas que tiene que ver con la
legalidad expulsar núcleos familiares de
la frontera suroeste
bajo el título 42 de hecho la corte
federal declaró que esta práctica era
ilegal lo que pasa es que la mitad corte
federal de apelaciones suspende la
implementación de la orden declarando la
práctica ilegal de tal manera que la
práctica sigue en efecto pero hubo
argumentos orales en la corte federal de
apelaciones del distrito de colombia el
19 de enero donde se está argumentando
precisamente la legalidad de todo esto
pero sorprendentemente la meditación
vaya seguido con la práctica la única
excepción que han permitido son menores
no acompañados de adultos ahora abogaba
para entender también un poco esta
medida se aplica digamos a las personas
que entran porque tipo de frontera
terrestre y también aérea o solamente
terrestre y terrestre en la frontera sur
oeste de los eeuu de américa
eso se está implementando esta práctica
todavía que dicho sea de paso durante el
transcurso de la administración by le
han expulsado 1 aproximadamente 1.2
millones de personas bajo el título 42
así que esto ha sido una práctica
bastante prevaleciente y todo con la
idea de controlar el flujo migratorio de
la frontera sur para no dar la
apariencia de un descontrol en la
frontera medidas como esta hace
realmente abogado que se frene la
migración no porque las personas siguen
viviendo bien sea por mar por vía aérea
o por vía terrestre porque hasta que no
respondan a las causas que originan la
isla inmigración es particularmente del
triángulo norte de centroamérica méxico
y en algunos casos en sur américa
técnicamente esto va a seguir sucediendo
aquí hay un problema que tiene dos
componentes el primer componente es
facilitar una inmigración legal desde el
exterior a través de procesos culturales
para por conceptos de reunificación
familiar y por concepto de refugio y
segundo
de legalizar más de 11 millones de
indocumentados que ya están dentro del
país y hasta que realmente no encuentren
soluciones para facilitar una
inmigración legal ordenada y correcta
desde puntos consulares y puertos de
entrada este flujo irregular migratorio
va a seguir existiendo claro pero por lo
menos digamos en el caso de los
venezolanos que es nuestro tema de hoy
cómo hacer esto cuando no hay
representación digamos oficial de
diplomáticos estadounidenses en
venezuela porque sabemos que las
relaciones entre ambos países están
rotas con el gobierno del presidente
nicolás maduro pues sin embargo también
en el juan guaidó el opositor tiene una
representación también en eeuu entonces
como juega este es digamos este juego de
poderes que hay en venezuela y que
realmente puede pasar para que estas
situaciones no se den no sé no sé no se
intensifiquen bueno y creo que las
medidas migratorias en realidad la
pueden tomar independientemente del
gobierno el régimen o el gobierno que
pueda estar en el poder por ejemplo en
el caso de
del tema de reunificación familiar en
estos momentos de eso tienes que acudir
a entrevista consular en bogotá entonces
y sabemos que estas entrevistas en gran
parte producto de la pandemia están
demorando muchísimo tiempo pero se
pudiera facilitar una inmigración
ordenada por reclamación familiar por el
concepto de pedir refugio desde el
exterior colaborar más con la acnur con
el proceso de reasentamiento de personas
que ya han sido declaradas refugiados no
es fácil pero hay que empezar a buscar
soluciones esta vez un programa de
parole para aquellas personas que ya
tienen el tps acá en eeuu donde puedan
traer a sus familiares de forma legal o
sea habilitar vías y procesos legales y
eso se puede hacer independientemente de
la colaboración del gobierno extranjero
para que estas personas en vez de
iniciar estas travesías tan peligrosas y
también que ponen en peligro la
seguridad nacional del país
sería la forma más correcta de tratar de
estrenar un poco este flujo mira tú
muy brevemente entonces qué está
haciendo la vicepresidenta cámara harris
en este aspecto porque ella es la
encargada digamos encargada del
presidente byte en para frenar esta
migración y parece que las cosas no
están mejorando
efectivamente se aparte de reunirse con
algunos de los países centroamericanos
es realmente todavía no hemos visto los
resultados de los esfuerzos que ha
podido tomar referente a el tema
migratorio en gran parte esto también
depende de acción legislativa que es
poco probable dada la dinámica política
en el país actualmente